One of the things that Carl Jung said
that I thought was really interesting
when he was talking about the Oedipal
situation and families,
I never forgot this,
so the Oedipal situation,
roughly speaking,
is when I'll,
I'll lay out the classic story is when a
child is seriously over-protected,
usually a male child by his mother.
Now the reverse can be the case and it
can be a female child by the mother and
all of that,
but I'll just talk about the classic
case to begin with.
Now.
What Freud observed was that there were
usually not very good boundaries in
families like that and so the
relationship between the husband and the
wife was either strange or nonexistent
and the wife would often turn to the
child to be what she isn't getting from
the husband,
and so there's a great south park
episode about this,
a wonderful south park episode where
they were.
I don't remember that horrible little
guy.
Is that.
That's him.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And his mother brings in the dog
whisperer to train him and it's
brilliant.
It's brilliant episode.
If you want to learn about Freud and
Freud and Oedipal situation,
you watch that.
You've got it down cold because she
brings in this expert who then she wants
to have an affair with,
so that's a boundary issue and he
basically separates her son from him and
and,
and imposes the same discipline on him
that he would get impose on a bad dog.
Although he also trains the dogs owners
all the time because maybe it's not the
dog.
Maybe it's the owner.
There's a horse whisperer movie too,
about the original horse whisperer.
That does a beautiful job of laying that
out too because he's very good at fixing
problem horses and unbelievably good at
diagnosing psychopathology on the part
of the owner.
It's his,
he's got a gift for it.
But anyways,
what happens in this South Park episode
is that the dog whisperer gets cartland
yeah.
Straightened out and he starts like
dressing properly and doing his homework
and,
and the mother is pursuing an affair
with the dog whisperer,
but he's professional.
He keeps his distance,
like he keeps boundaries around him and
then he leaves.
And then the first thing that she does
when he leaves his bride carton and
basically out of doing his homework so
that he can accompany her to,
I don't know,
a fast food restaurant or something like
that.
And so the reason she does that is
because she's lonesome and doesn't have
anybody else around.
And you know,
maybe she's also deeply,
deeply,
deeply terrified that if she helps that
boy grow up,
he will leave and she'll have nothing,
you know.
And so mothers who don't have something
say outside their infants,
not merely their children are more
likely to fall into that.
And it's no wonder,
you know,
you got to think that through.
And lots of women really,
most women really fall in love with
their babies,
you know.
And so even if they start growing into
larger children,
that can be threatening because,
well,
when that,
when the child turns into,
when the infant turns into a toddler
that the infant is dead,
the toddler is there now.
And you can radically interfere with
that process.
That happens all the time,
all the time.
That's the classic Freud in Eda pulled
nightmare.
And that episode is brilliant,
it's bloody brilliant,
it just nails it and some of you have
been in my personality class and watched
crumb the documentary crum,
and that's another staggering exposition
of exactly that kind of pathology.
Anyways,
one of the things you pointed out,
so I knew this guy once who had a mother
who basically was trying that trick and
she had lots of.
She was very smart and had lots of
tricks up our sleeves and there's just
no way he was going to go for.
He rebelled at every possible moment and
he basically became,
I would say,
somewhat hypermasculine in response,
which is a.
which is an interesting lesson with
regards to the hypermasculinity that
boys often develop if they're raised by
single mothers because they tend to go
one of two ways and he just thought her
at every step of the way and it didn't
happen.
But one of the things you said,
which I loved,
and you can really see this in the
chrome documentary,
is that the eternal mother basically
entices.
The child says,
look,
here's the deal.
You don't have to do anything but you
don't get to leave,
but if you don't leave and you don't do
these difficult things,
then I'll take care of you and the child
has a choice all the way along there.
I mean,
obviously he's outclassed in some sense,
but it's not as obvious as you'd think.
Little kids are tough and they make
decisions all the time and so Jung
thought about it more as a conspiracy
than as something imposed on the child
by the mother and I really like.
It's actually a conspiracy between
mother,
father,
and child actually and I think that's a
good way of looking at it even though
it's really rough because said,
well,
should you hold a child responsible?
Well,
yes,
but judiciously and not completely
because then if you deal with someone
like that as an adult and they're trying
to escape from it,
you have to go all the way back and
figure out how the hell had happened and
then they have to adjust.
They have to figure out where they
opened the door,
like inviting a vampire in because they
can't come in unless you invite them in,
you know,
so don't invite them in because once
they're in,
they're really hard to get rid of and
they'll take all your blood.
So that's a cautionary tale.